un invité qui est avec nous depuis le
début de l'émission je disais c'est
Samuel Samia qui est bassiste de saymani
hein c'est un trio de jazz originaire
des Yvelines et je le disais tout à
l'heure vous serez vous du côté
d'Élancourt il y aura aussi une date
dimanche qu'on va annoncer dans un
instant mais à Élancourt ce sera samedi
pour la fête de la réouverture de la
médiathèque des 7 morts jouer pour la
réouverture d'un lieu culturel qui a été
fermé au puits pendant plusieurs mois
pour des travaux ça vous fait quoi c'est
intéressant pour vous oui on l'a déjà
fait du coup pour je crois que c'est un
voisin de mémoire enfin d'aller dernière
effectivement aussi un lieu d'animation
bah c'est entre gens que la musique
c'est sa vie aussi du coup c'est pas que
une déranger de CD dans une médiathèque
c'est aussi des éléments liants alors
c'est Manu je disais c'est un trio trois
personnes alors vous êtes le bassiste il
y a aussi Yann garrot le batteur et
aussi Emilio Anto Fermo le guitariste
alors pour se faire une idée on va
écouter un extrait d'un clip c'est
cheese anywhere and nowhere
[Musique]
qui était un extrait du premier album
qui est sorti il y a un an alors chose
intéressante aussi vous avez rejoint le
trio l'été dernier c'est ça vous êtes
récemment donc vous avez récemment
intégré le groupe comment vous l'avez
rejoint comment ça c'est fait moi je
connaissais Yann on était quasiment au
collège ensemble donc il y a quelques
années donc on se connaissait jamais
perdu puis en fait voilà les échanges
sont faits comme ça ils cherchaient un
Boissy et puis j'étais disponible à ce
moment-là donc on a pu intégrer la
formation il n'y a pas de chanteur
d'ailleurs dans c'est la musique qui
prime pourquoi ce choix
parce que on est plus
les notes sont plus universelles que les
paroles donc on a choisi effectivement
de pouvoir s'exprimer par la musique et
les mélodies qui sont choisies plutôt
que les paroles tout simplement et le
jazz alors pourquoi est-ce que c'est
c'est une musique qui trouve encore son
public est-ce que c'est pas une musique
juste de spécialiste le jazz
on essaie de casser les barrières
justement parce que jazz enfin déjà ça
veut tout dire c'est toutes les musiques
en fait toutes les musiques viennent
probablement de
soit du gospel soit du jazz enfin c'est
un petit peu donc on casse on casse les
limites donc il y a du binaire il y a du
il y a du ternaire comme je vous disais
il y a toutes sortes de pulsations
toutes sortes d'ambiance par rapport à
différents morceaux qui ont proposé
effectivement et vous arrivez à
intéresser toutes les générations
justement sur le jazz justement on a
fait plusieurs concepts notamment à
médiathèque la dernière fois c'était les
gens étaient vraiment surpris parce que
jazz mais c'est c'est de la musique on
fait donc ça varie chacun a sa propre
sensibilité par rapport à la musique
Régine est-ce que justement vous vous
produisez aussi en dehors des frontières
du de des Yvelines est-ce que vous avez
déjà fait des concerts pas pour ma part
encore mais pour le groupe une séance
pas mal notamment enfin dans le fameuse
rue des Lombards aux ducs il y a des il
y a pas mal de concert effectivement qui
ont lieu tu peux partout en France mais
tout à fait et là donc du coup on a
Chartres le dimanche pour le festival
Jazz
pour samedi vous serez à Chartres le
dimanche en dehors des Yvelines mais bon
voilà vous êtes originaire que vous êtes
ici bien sûr pour pour en parler vous
influences à vous et au groupe et ce qui
en a qui qui ressortent dans dans les
dans les les productions du coup
oui nécessairement déjà on inspirait des
trio tout ça qui ont marqué l'histoire
du jazz pour ma part c'est plus moderne
c'est tout ce qui est par exemple
chicoréa Electric bang ou acoustique par
exemple mais c'est aussi des trio un peu
plus modernes comme nec plus qui sont
des trio très moderne aujourd'hui qui
sont plus jazz fusion
jazzy et est-ce que alors le jazz ça
laisse pas aussi sur les sur les scènes
à une part d'improvisation ça vous
arrive aussi régulièrement
oui c'est en fait les morceaux se
présentent effectivement comme une
structure jazz il y a l'intro le thème
est exposé et ensuite effectivement
chacun la possibilité de s'exprimer
aussi bien la guitare à la base que la
batterie en fonction des éléments et
puis ensuite on rejoint le thème puis la
fin le régime vous aviez une autre
question
l'autre question c'est pourquoi avoir
choisi un titre en anglais
voilà le titre
sont tout le temps en anglais non pas
forcément
et donc il y a un an sortait le l'album
c'est humaniste et le premier album du
groupe est-ce qu'il y a de nouveau
projet musicaux
très vite avant au courant 2023 on
espère début 2024 effectivement il sera
essentiellement des titres de cet album
qui seront joués qui seront jamais
samedi ou de nouvelles de nouvelles
compositions effectivement mais oui
c'est principalement des titres du de la
bonne actuelle donc on pourra vous
écouter du côté de la médiathèque des 7
mars samedi pour le trio saymani à
l'occasion je le disais de la fête de la
réouverture de la médiathèque qui a lieu
samedi du côté d'Élancourt merci Samuel
Samira d'être venu en parler en plateau
d'être venu présenter ce groupe saymani
un trio de jazz je disais originaire des